ということで私の高校時代の話なんですけどもええまあみたいな通りのですね私高校
まあ怖いよな雰囲気の高校でまぁ本当に俗にいう不良高校というところを出身でですね
まあ大学なんてほっ誰一人も行かないようなまあ高校出身だったですねまぁそこで高校
2年生の時にあのまあ基本的主
属する高校だったんで就職を考えているところで
まあ好きなこと何かなって思っている時にあの一番
まぁ最初に思ったのが低日しかなくてもうテレビドラマを見るのが好きだったんで
まあテレビドラマのを作るっていうことでテレビ局受けようかなと思って
そしてそこなのよく就職もありますよね今井3年生もいい
かもしれないで就職後読んでたらなんと私フジテレビ来たかったんですけど
フジテレビの合格している大学が東京大学早稲田大学慶應義塾大学一橋大学はするあの
明治大学立教大付私からするともう超難関大学でまぁそんなところ受かるはずもないし
うちの高校から誰一人も入ってないし
みたいな
あまあところだったんですけれどもやっぱり急にやっぱり目的ができるですね勉強する
んですね
そこでですね猛勉強を始めて高校2年生の秋からなんとあの
イチローで明治大学あの合格しまして
うちの空港発っていうところで入ったんですけれども
この中で私がいるのが実はここあれ
ちっいうかなこれが
ここから生まれまた動かないというア動いた
ボタンを押してもらえればじゃあ俺あのこちら効かなくなったんでまたこれもトラブル
なんですけどもこれが私だということですねはいじゃあ次っていただいて
はいそこでまぁ度かけるエンターテイメントって書いてあるんですけれども
じゃあ大学あの入ってからやっぱり体
曲にどうしても行きたくてでちょうど3年生の時にやっぱりテレビ局受けたわけですね
在京のテレビ局からあとはコンサートの運営会社とかそういうエンターテインメントの
世界行きたくて受けたんですけどもうまくいかないものですね
就職全滅全部落ちました本当に最悪の状況
ので結構打ち込んだんですけどもまぁその中で実は次に入ったのが
旅行会社で
旅行会社に入ってそこでちょっと度もエンターテインメントかなぁと思いながら
はじめはちょっとやってたんですけどもやっぱりエンターテイメントの世界を忘れられ
なくて
そこで考えたのが度かけるエンターテイメントってこっからが掛け算の始まりなんです
ね
でまぁあの皆さん旅掛エンターテイメントどう想像されるか分からないんですけど
も私が最初にこれやったのがはい
8うんこチェーン書いての音楽力って番組でこれフジテレビの番組なんですけどもまぁ
あのこうエンターテイメントの世界の方とたくさん人脈ができてですね
でそうしましたらあるプロダクションの社長さんがそんなにテレビ作りたいになったら
一緒にやろうよっていうことを言ってくれて
でまぁこれはまさに音楽と旅を掛け合う
させるえっ
あのまあなんですかね8番組なんですけれども
じゃあ皆さんにここでまた質問ですはい
皆さんリバプールって言ったらなんだどこか
リバブルって言った何を想像しますかね音楽と旅 day
あっさすがですねビートルですよね
先ほどクラシックがあったんで
プラハと言ったらクラシックの世界で有名な曲があるんですけれども
わかりますがクラシックやっていること
先ほどあの歌っていらっしゃったんですけどモルダウっていう進めたの曲ですね
まあそういうふうに音楽の旅を結びつゲート世界各国にあってこれを私は旅行会社とし
て在外視点から情報収集して
でそれを番組の番組の方は8作ってですね制作会社がそう
してプロダクションの人はゆうゆうさんを連れていくというようなで体日曲お金を出す
という三者ウィンの世界で成り立つような番組私も10年間これをずっと担当してい
ました
まあこういうことが正がテレビ局に行かずに8こういうことができるようになるなんて
思ってもなかったんですね
で続いてですねあのはい
こちらはですねええ音楽まああの当時 cd とか大変売れてた時代なんでその cd
のジャケットとかですね
あとポスターとかまあそういうものを作るということがあってこれはあのえっと誰
アーティストさんのデモテープを最初に聞かせていただいてそれをイメージするような
場所を提案するということです
でそこに行くということでこれイタリアのサントリーニ島って凄いきれいなところなん
ですけども私がずっと行きたかったところで提案していけるようになったっていう
まあ本当に私が一番嬉しかったみたいな思い出に残りましたですね
あと続いてですねこれはあの子の中の方でもタレントさんもう大ファンという方
いらっしゃいませんぱ
グローブぐらいに入っているとかていらっしゃいます
あまり言えないかなというところでね入ってくることで
あのそうなんですタレントさんのファンクラブツアーっていうのありましてこれは
すごくたくさんやってるんですけども
やはり大好きなタレントさんと一緒に旅ができてそして一緒に写真が撮れるって
やっぱり大ファンの人にとっては嬉しいですよね
まあこういうことで
旅かける色てエンターテインメントと仕事はたくさんあってですね
まああのその道絶技はいやっていただいてそこで私が入社8年目の時に芸能界の専門
セクションっていうのを作って
まあこういう旅かけるエンターテイメントというのを始めたということです
はい
でまぁその後にあの皆さんも映画を見られてこの町に行きたいということありませんか
ね
はい
まあそういうことでスクリーンツーリズムという考え方で
学生の皆さんはこの銀の匙ってよく知ってると思うんですけども
帯広が舞台でで帯広から帯色に行きたくなりはそういったもので旅行会社としても支援
していくということで一緒に映画を作るとかですね
まあそういうことをやっていましたはいただいい言葉
歌詞ではなくてですね今までいい話でしたんですけれども最悪な事件が起きましてです
ね
今話題のいろいろと音集観測もありますけれども
私も本当にすっぱ抜かれてですねええこういうことをやってたら
出る杭は打たれるというのかですね a
まあエンターテイメントをこうやってていろんな仕事をどんどんしてたので
そしたらあのまあ取材が来たんで話をしたわけですね
そしたら題名がなんとお忍び力を着たままで走って雄大で
加えは8夕刊フジの芸能欄に私はその旅行会社で初めてでてさよね
データ男みたいな感じでまああんまり芸能
に普通の一般人が出ることはないんですけどもまぁそこでこういうことをやってたと
いうことでまぁ非常に当時
後方出場から呼び出しされてですね大ピンチになったまあそういうこともあったという
ことですねまぁ良いこともあれば悪いこともあるということで皆さんね感じて
いただければなというふうに思います
はいということでその後はですね実は度かけるコスメって書いてある
ですけれども
皆さんもですね度皆さん旅行旅行嫌いな方っていらっしゃいます
n 4の情報
式が海外の常識じゃないということはよくわかりました
その一番は日本ではレストランに行けば
おしぼりは必ず出てくるなぜか海外に行くと高級レストランですが
おしぼりが出てこないなんでだろう本当に思いましたね
でもこれなんだろで月すべても出てこないわけですでも日本人相手にしてからになって
いる
ので次のこれは私はあの
8化粧品会社のドクターシーラボと一緒にですね航空んでですねええ
殺菌のジェルですね今だと当たり前なジェルなんですけども
当時こういうものはあんまりなくてですねそれで飛行機って100ミリ以下じゃないと
持ち込めないので50mm 後住民のサイズにして被圧もかかるので気圧をかけられ
あのつか買っても大丈夫で容器を硬くするとか
あの旅の視点でこういうものを作ったりとかですねはい
ます
次はですねあの皆さん
オーストラリアに行かれた方ってのお願いします5世代に行ったことあるかと
あっ結構いらっしゃいますよねオーストラリアで困った事ってなんか感じません
ゴーストラリーやね
私をそろえて一番すでにいつも何回も繰り返して行ってしまうんですけど日焼けなん
ですね
はぁこれはのお一人あり便というのは
here よる出るんですね成田空港よるいて朝つくんで朝ツイート9旅行会社はその
後コアラとか立っ抱かせるたんですね
あのそういう動物園とかに行って1日
すごさして夕方にホテルにチェックインするっていうのは通常なんですね
でそうするとコアガード抱いている時にはもう嬉しくてその瞬間にどんどん日焼けをし
てしまうということでなんでこんなに焼けるかというと日本の紫外線の5倍って言われ
てるんですね
ですから紫外線量が全然違うとじゃあ何か紫外線のチェッカーができるものができたら
いいなぁと
持って作ったのがこう言う uv のキャップのどこで紫外線の色が変わるっていう
まあそんなもの作ってですねはいあとは次はですね
まああの球と私の友達が
8ネイル会社の大手ネイル会社のトップにいたのでまぁこんな話をしている中で
ネイルも結構女性の中であの傷がついたりとかいろんなことがあるんだよねっていう
ことで実は携帯用のネイルの修正ができる
こういうパッケージを作ったりとかですねまぁそんなことを実はやっててあの
8コスメ事業っていうのをこういうふうに会社の中で作ってしまったと
まあこういうイノベーションをどんどん起こすというんですねはい
次はですねこうマーケティングずっとやってましたら私もやっぱりそのマーケティング
が大好きになってきて
でそこでの1階ですね隣にあるリバティアカデミーですね
のところでちょうどマーケティングの授業が土曜日に行ってたんで
1日講座で習いに行くことにしたですね一家言1年間でそうしたらあの明治大学の
いろんな商学部のせい
やてぃひ*
朝に実戦でをシール事業今落ちていることを学生にマーケティングを教えるっていう
明治大学としてはたち的な事業を始めましたら商学部ですごくまあ人気事業に
まあなりましてよる6弦という終わるのが9時10分に終わるのに
まあすごい多くの方が受けていただいてでまあそれが続いて今なんと明治大学の商学部
の
特別招聘9人になってしまうという仕事しながらなんかこういうこともやってたりとか
ですね
ですねあとはこれをやってたらこの会社からですね
明治でこんなことやってる人がいるって言う事で今度立教大学の観光学部っていうのが
あってそこからですね
オファーが来てなんと今度は平日堂々と昼間にですね立教大学の観光学部で私は4軒の
昼間の授業を教えることになってしまうとかですね
で次これなんと今度は明治がこういうことをやっていることで早稲田大学が産学連携を
強化すると150年に向けてということで
で15個も教えられる社会人とあまりないんですよね
ゲストスピーカーでハナセルライトができるんですけどもということでここにいるじゃ
ないかという事ですぐオーバーが来てなんと今
をやったんですけど早稲田大学の非常勤講師もやっているという
何と私残念わかんなくなってきたですねで次にですね
あの学生たたくさん知り合ったんですね今日もたくさん来ていただいてますけど
で学生さんと言ってたらじゃあマーケティングとやっぱりじっ春季行ったりといけない
し
戦わないといけないということで私が大学行きたかった合わせると9と明示
戦わせようっていうことを考えてですねそれで早慶明対抗のマーケティングコンテス
トっていうのは今年で4回目やってんですけどねですね
去年ことで去年はちょっと残念ながら慶應義塾大が優勝してしまって
で ko が今当社に来て新商品を開発してまーさ
来年ぐらいには商品化できると言うまあ実践をやらせたいという私やっぱり
ビジネスマンなんでええまあ
学問ではなくて実践というところを教えるってまあそういうことを実はやっ
いるとですねで今度はを教えてたらですね
やっぱり人って面白くて学びたくなるんですよ系でこれが強度今から2年前に新聞記事
で慶應義塾大学がなんとエグゼクティブ mba
ですね mba の一つ上のこれを日本で初めて開校するっていう記事
みましてこれだと思って受験しましてまた
また勉強して試験勉強してですね受けてですね
なんとあんだけねえ狙ってた慶應義塾大学に30年後のリベンジで合格しましてですね
今私は慶應義塾大学修士課程の1年生でもあると言う
あの
は不思議なことを実はやってるっていうまあそういうことですねはーい
まあそういうことが高じてまたマーケティングとこう今のお話するとやっぱり人脈って
とか非常に高人とにつながって分かっていただいたと思うんですけども
そこでマークマーケティングやってたらやっぱり化粧品会社っていうのはあの
マーケティングの一番強い会社でもあるので
まぁそこが実は25年前にですねええ
その芸能界でいると仕事してた時の仲間が実は起業した会社
あでそこで私がずーっと付き合ってたのでじゃあ家に来てマーケティングやんじゃない
かって言われていきなり多分旅行会社から化粧品会社のマーケティングのトップやって
取締役になるということはリレーだと思うんですけどもまぁそこで今こうくっついて
しまったと
ですねー
あとは私の友達が実は角川でへ
まあ編集をやっててはいお前お前の人生非常にビジネスマンとして変わってるから本
出さないかということになって私はあの実は国語が小学校から一番苦手ですね
もう国語って書くことが一番やだったんですけれどもまあ本当に彼がですね赤ペン先生
をやってくれてですね
なんと2冊の本を書くこと
になってしまったとかですねほんと人生わからないなっていうのが
まあ今の現状なんですねでまぁこちらほんと掛け算
からまあ今お話しさせていただいたんです本当掛け算掛け算をやっていることで
どんどんの高リノベーションがつながってくるっていうことで
まあ皆さんもねどうですかね第なくちょっと掛け算分かってきたと思うんですけども
a
皆さんから問題振っていただいてもいいんですけどもまぁちょっと時間の関係もあるの
で今私が一番ちょっと気になる掛け算っていうのが明治大学でねせっかく3時代かなん
で
明治大学の農学部がやってる掛け算なんですねこれは
あの農業と
工場っていうところを掛け合わせて植物工場は明治が結構最先端をいってる技術を持っ
てるんですけど
まああの黒カー向上とかに農場とか行くとそこの最先端の技術のものが見れるんです
けども私は女だと結構感動してですね
もしかしてことないに普通に白衣着た人が農業をやる時代が来る
んじゃないかとまあそういうことでまぁこういう掛け算のこの想像力を生かすことが
多分一番重要なんじゃないかなっていうふうに思っています
であとはよく学生から質問でこの想像力をつけるためにどうしたらいいかとかってよく
まあ聞かれるんですけども
私がよく答えるところの一番この明治大学の学生にいつも言っているのはあの皆さん台
で御茶ノ水から駅から来ますよね
a
今日も多分明治の学生さんだったら御茶ノ水から来てここにすぐこれたと思うんです
けれども
これって日常じゃないですか
ですけど例えば新宿方面から来るんだったら
水道橋で降りなさいって言う言うんですねこれ水道橋で降りると降りて20分で目時代
からこれますもう目線が全くあります
道歩いているときにいろんなものが見えていくんですねはい日常だと多分惰性で明治大
いくまで来ているので途中どんな看板があるから
と覚えてもないんですけどもまぁそういうところからこの想像力を発するっていう
ところが毎日上のことだったりとかあと本当に電車を乗ってる時に誰からね
毎日何やってんだとか
まあそんなを見たりとかですねまあそういうことをしているとだんだん
できていくと後に家に本当に今すぐだと小さいものが大きくなったらどうなるかとかと
待っているものは動いたらどうなるかとかまあそういうことを常にこう考えていると
いろんなことが想像できるんですよねっていうことでまぁ皆さんもですね
あのかけ the 人生ですねエコー
いうことをまあ今日のちょっと話をしてちょっとも共感いただいたですね
今日から一つでも今日の帰り水道橋まで歩いて何でもいいんですけども
そんなことから始めていただくと面白い人生がですね
くるんではないかなと思いますありがとうございました